so glycol which we watch that yeah hello
there welcome to this extremely
scientific episode in slow mo guys we're
in a lab yeah for once or twice unlap
post make sense
yeah GE actually flew us all the way to
New York to their labs which is awesome
in Toronto motherland and everything
yeah they want us to film a bunch of
their technology so we got to start with
this video we've also done two other
videos on GES channel so be sure to
check those out check check check those
out yeah so this video we've got some
super hydrophobic material - man-made is
act similar to lotus leaf so if you were
to alter that shows it he has which is
right off yeah that's a hydrophobic
material this one here is man-made we're
going to test that with some Foucault in
water and get nights over so the way it
works in nature is that there's actually
tiny nanoscopic hairs on the plant
there's trap a layer of air and that
causes the war just not to go to
penetrate there's basically just about
to your air they're trapped this is the
man-made version so we're going to take
the Phantom I'm going to take a macro
lens and it's some super close-up shots
of the way water reacts on a super
hydrophobic surface
science women time to get four outs of
food chlorine-containing here we're
going to pour it onto the surface all at
the same time hopefully get a nice
collision you get a nice collisions or
splooshing yeah good work there's the
technical term yeah I believe so we've
got red and blue red and blue people
for us
great Duke one through
I want to see the ocean I've seen robots
but now that's ridiculous
like I saw just looks like a flower it
spreads out completely
yeah bounces are so weird is really good
all right so now we'll try that again
but backlight it so you can see through
the liquid three two one
so another thing that happens is that
iron filings in water when the magnet
goes up to them it's very easy to
differentiate the iron filings from the
liquid if the iron filings have been
shaved down to a nanoscopic scale you
basically get metallic liquid like tell
no to me it looks like sweet it looks
like the team on that is so cool okay so
here is the fairest liquid so it's got
the nano sized iron filings and iron
particles in there okay this is a magnet
I'm going to place the magnet down the
test tube like this okay and then lift
up liquid towards the magnet and watch
it give it a go gets attracted see I
like indents before it like pushes down
and then shoots up and end up with a
basically a magnetic ball it's really
cool
I'm not so good even so attracts the
other business
yeah see how that left
yeah yeah and I keep the plate angled
slightly towards the camera no we're
okay really
yeah well alright that's good
we
I just love the way that it sorry
there's no need for that sorry this was
literally ground that I'm actually has
literally been in use for about this
well I hope you enjoyed that video can't
really get all the liquids they always
look good so be sure to follow us on
Twitter and also check out the two
videos we made for GES channel one is
called MEMS the others cool cold spray
and if you're intrigued by then given we
click in the watch out
yes sir we've got to get escorted out
there yeah yeah I'm going to say I
trusted